-Performing "Holy Water"
from his new album
"Songs About You," please
welcome Brett Eldredge.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ I've been on the verge
of breakin' ♪
♪ Couldn't find my way
outta here ♪
♪ I saw you standin' there,
wavin' ♪
♪ Makin' all this hell
disappear ♪
♪ You are my holy water ♪
♪ You are my river thee ♪
♪ Wash me away
and take me higher ♪
♪ 'Cause somethin' 'bout
your love just sets me free ♪
♪ Somethin' 'bout your love
just sets me free ♪
♪ I had my time bein' reckless ♪
♪ Holdin' back my heart
for too long ♪
♪ And all those empty nights
made me helpless ♪
♪ And I was fadin' like the end
of a song ♪
♪ Uh ♪
♪ You are my holy water ♪
♪ You are my river thee ♪
♪ Wash me away
and take me higher ♪
♪ 'Cause somethin' 'bout
your love just sets me free ♪
♪ Somethin' 'bout your love
just sets me free ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ And I got used to
broken hearts ♪
♪ Watchin' my world fall apart ♪
♪ Didn't know I needed you
but now I do, now I do ♪
♪ Ohhhhhhh ♪
♪ You are my holy water ♪
♪ You are my river thee ♪
♪ Wash me away
and take me higher ♪
♪ 'Cause somethin' 'bout
your love just sets me free ♪
♪ Somethin' 'bout your love
just sets me free ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]